.
I KNOW YOU DIDN'T PLAN TO DO TV
TONIGHT SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
IT.
THANK YOU.
JOINING ME NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH,
FORMER HOUSE SPEAKER AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, WHY CAN'T
WE LEARN ABOUT EVERYONE WHO WAS
SHADOW BANNED?
JUST MINUTES AGO ELON MUSK
TWEETED THAT THEY ARE WORKING ON
A SOFTWARE UPDATE TO SHOW YOU
YOUR TRUE ACCOUNT STATUS TO SHOW
IF YOU CLEARLY HAVE BEEN SHADOW
BANNED.
THE REASON WHY YOU WERE AND TO
APPEAL IT.
SHOULD ANY OF THIS DEPUTIES IN
ANY ITERATION AT THIS POINT?
>> I THINK ALL OF IT SHOULD COME
OUT IN THE OPEN.
IT'S AMAZING THAT HERE IS A
FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANT TO
AMERICA, WHO IS DOING MORE TO
UPHOLD AMERICAN VALUES, THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, YOUR RIGHT OF
FREE SPEECH, THAN ANYBODY WE'VE
EVER SEEN.
IT'S REMARKABLE WHAT HE'S DONE
SO FAR.
I HOPE HE'LL HAVE THE COURAGE TO
CONTINUE AND LET IT ALL OUT
THERE.
I MEAN, PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW
WHAT WAS GOING ON, AND THEN THE
CHALLENGE COMES TO FACEBOOK AND
TO GOOGLE, TO MATCH THAT KIND OF
OPENNESS BECAUSE FRANKLY, THEY
HAVE BEEN AT LEAST AS BAD, AND
GOOGLE IN SOME WAYS, HAS BEEN
WORSE, I THINK, THAN IT WAS
TWITTER.
AND THESE SYSTEMS ARE SO
GIGANTIC, THEY ARE SO POWERFUL,
AND THEY ARE SO MUCH IN
EVERYBODY'S LEAVES THAT THEY
HAVE TO BE TRANSPARENT, OR WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
PRETTY DRAMATIC TO LIMIT THEIR
CAPACITY.
>> LAURA: ISN'T THIS NOW BEYOND
OBVIOUS THAT CONGRESS DOES HAVE
TO STEP IN HERE?
I MEAN, REPUBLICANS ALWAYS WANT
TO TAKE A HANDS OFF APPROACH TO
BIG BUSINESS BUT WE'VE SEEN, AND
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS, THAT TIME AND AGAIN, BIG
BUSINESS, NOT THE 1980s ANYMORE,
HAS BECOME DIAMETRICALLY OPPOSED
TO THE AMERICAN TRADITION OF
FREE SPEECH, SECOND AMENDMENT,
PARENTAL RIGHTS, ET CETERA, ET
CETERA, AND THE WOKENESS, AND
THE DISINFORMATION, CAMPAIGNS,
ALL OF THAT, IS PART OF IT.
>> WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS WHAT
ORIGINALLY FASCISM WAS ALL ABOUT
WHICH IS THE IDEA THAT BIG
GOVERNMENT GETS TOGETHER WITH
BIG BUSINESS TO CONTROL THE
COUNTRY AGAINST SMALL BUSINESS
AND AGAINST INDIVIDUALS.
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
FIND OUT, WHAT WE'RE BEGINNING
TO FIND OUT IS, THAT THE F.B.I.
WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN ALL OF
THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT, I
THINK, THAT THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL, THAT DR. FAUCI,
REMEMBER, HE'S A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL.
HE'S NOT JUST A CELEBRITY.
HE'S A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL WITH
CERTAIN OBLIGATIONS AND CERTAIN
RESPONSIBILITIES, AND I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT, ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE WERE VIOLATING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, BEHAVING
ILLEGALLY, AND THAT THIS IS A
MUCH DEEPER AND BIGGER MESS THAN
PEOPLE REALIZE.
>> LAURA: I WANT TO PLAY THIS
SMALL MOMENT FROM THIS GUY, JUST
TWO WEEKS AGO DEFENDING THE
TWITTER PROTOCOLS.
>> WE HAD A SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE.
RULES-BASED.
WE ENFORCED OUR RULES AS
WRITTEN.
WE CHANGED OUR RULES IN WRITING,
WE DID IT TRANSPARENTEELY AND
WHEN THAT SYSTEM OF GOVERNANCE
WENT AWAY --
>> LAURA: FOR TWITTER TO CLAIM
THEY WERE TRANSPARENT, NOW WITH
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE SEEING,
IT'S JUST OFFENSIVE.
>> LAURA, I DON'T QUITE KNOW FOR
REASONABLE PEOPLE HOW YOU GET
ACROSS THE IDEA, THESE PEOPLE
ARE JUST LIARS.
IT'S NOT COMPLICATED.
THEY ARE LIARS.
THEY LIE ALL THE TIME.
THEY HAVE TOTAL CONTEMPT FOR THE
REST OF US.
THEY THINK THEY CAN BREAK THE
RULES AND GET AWAY WITH IT.
THEY THINK THEY ARE SOMEHOW THIS
ELITE THAT'S ABOVE US AND THAT
WE'RE TOO STUPID TO KNOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND ALL TOO OFTEN,
AND THIS IS THE CASE, BY THE
WAY, WRITE THINK KEVIN McCARTHY
IS SHOWING THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP
WITH PEOPLE LIKE ADAM SCHIFF,
WHO WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, JUST
ROUTINELY LIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
TOTALLY MISINFORMED THEM.
THERE OUGHT TO BE A CONSEQUENCE
AND WE OUGHT TO START WITH
SIMPLE OLD FASHION LANGUAGE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE LIARS.
THEY OUGHT TO BE OSTRACIZED,
KICK OUT OF POLITE SOCIETY IF
THERE IS SUCH A THING ANYMORE.
WE SHOULDN'T KID OURSELVES.
I DON'T NEED ANY COMPL